c'est dans une bulle de ténèbres que les
douze jeunes et leur entraîneur de
soccer sont restés prisonniers pendant
18 jours il va absolument pas de
nourriture et heureusement il y avait de
l'eau de l'eau fraîche et propre qui
coulait donc qu'ils souhaitaient des
parois qui pouvaient mois les champs où
les stalactites le coach
il a 25 ans il a passé déjà dix ans de
sa vie comme moine bouddhiste il a donc
expliqué aux gamins voilà on sait pas
combien de temps on va rester ici donc
nous allons faire des petites séances de
méditation qui peuvent durer quelques
minutes et ça permet de conserver
l'énergie de réduire le stress vous de
remonter un peu le moral
[Musique]
dans le récit prise au piège de thierry
falise on en apprend plus on réalise à
quel point sans un incroyable concours
de circonstances sans un enchaînement de
heureux hasard
les treize jeunes serait à coup sûr mort
au fond de la grotte pour secourir les
enfants l'armée thaïlandaise fait appel
à ses meilleurs plongeurs mais les six
thaïlandais sont experts en eau libre
ils n'arrivent pas à pénétrer les
passages étroits inondée d'eau boueuse
et opaque centre de plongée qui ne
pardonne pas dans une autre tous les
plongeurs l'ont comparé à du café au
lait et paix la visibilité de quelques
centimètres
parfois vous ne voyez absolument pas
voué à 10 cm et que des courants qui
vous ballotte qui vous qui vous projette
sur les parois latérales ou sur le sur
le plafond premier coup de chance un
spéléologue expérimenté ainsi villes
britanniques arrivent sur place dans les
premières heures prête à offrir son aide
aux secouristes de l'armée thaïlandaise
il est là heureusement et lui connaît
très bien la grotte
il est allé plusieurs fois il a fait des
relevés topographiques etc
et puis surtout il s'apprête à y aller
lonmin lui-même
non seulement le spéléologue running
wilde connaît très bien la grotte
il a aussi en poche le nom et les
contacts de trois plongeurs souterrain
parmi les meilleurs au monde et par
chance dont les trois sons sont
disponibles l'intelligent je pense de ce
régime a été ravalé leur fierté
nationaliste
les thaïlandais ont donc été à mon avis
très malin en disant aux étrangers bah
écoutez vous vous pouvez faire ça donc
on va vous donner toutes les facilités
pour le faire après dix jours de
recherche
les plongeurs britanniques retrouve
enfin les 12 jeunes et leur entraîneur
quand on sort s'est terminée qu'on a su
ce qu'il avait fait pour ses gosses
évidemment il est devenu un des héros si
vous voulez de de cette histoire et puis
grand partie grâce à lui que ces gosses
ont réussi à tenir tenir le coup
psychologiquement
mais retrouver les enfants n'est qu'une
partie de l'exploit pour sortir de là il
faudra un autre mirage et puis surtout
il commence à manquer d'oxygène le taux
d'oxygène commencé à baisser
sérieusement
à la surface les parents pris les moines
bouddhistes implorent les esprits
d'épargner leurs enfants à première vue
le sauvetage de ces jeunes semble une
tâche impossible
il ya deux passages extrêmement
difficiles dont un qui est qui fait 38
cm de haut donc c'est pas ça ça fait
cinq mois et 72 de large 1 sur 4 5 m il
faut pas c'est que l'équipe en est un
être humain ce qui pèse 30 kg voir un
gamin et on voit rien du tout rapidement
mais secouriste réalise qu'il sera
impossible de sortir ces jeunes
réveiller avec un enfant éveillé ou en
moitiés éveillé c'était courir à la mort
certaine et donc la seule solution
c'était de les endormir par miracle il y
a dans la petite communauté des
plongeurs souterrain un médecin
anesthésiste
le docteur richard harris viendra
d'australie pour un atelier les enfants
c'est une histoire je pense qui a
fasciné le monde parce que d'abord ce
sont des enfants c'est sûr que si
ç'avait été des adultes ont leurs aînés
mais qu'est-ce que vous fait chier la
bande d'abrutis comme au retour
là ce sont 10 des enfants elle s'est
bien terminée il ya eu malheureusement
la mort d'un plongeur taille devient
aussi le cette partie des mythologies
matin il ya eu un héros taille un martyr
quelque part prise au piège c'est un
récit le courage de résilience mais
aussi un enchaînement de rebondissements
qui sera assurément un jour porté au
grand écran
[Musique]